The landscape gizmo brush is one of the other tools that we can use to
So a few moments of silence to match the background and the levels of noise in the room in
this part of level editing I'd like to
in this part of level at in
This part of level editing. I'd like to talk about level instanced actors
level instanced actors allow you to take a single static mesh that's been instanced multiple times or used multiple different places or a
group of static meshes and replace them with a
new
version that under the hood
replaces all of those static meshes with instanced versions of themselves increasing speed and
reusability. The image in front of us or the slide
I should say in front of us shows this in action with the sandstone rocks.
The image that you're seeing is actually constructed using the four sandstone rocks and
We can do this inside of the editor by doing the following so in our scene here
I have these rocks and if I hit shift E
I'm going to go through and actually select a few more as this is made up of quite a few different
Types of rocks and things like that just to kind of show you the versatility of this
When I've done that I have 47
Actors selected so what I'm going to do now is I'm going to right-click and I'm going to go to level
We're going to go create level instanced. Now when we do this
We're going to get the new level instanced dialog box and what this is allowing us to do is select the pivot point
For this object and we have some options here
We have center min Z which is going to find the minimum Z value and center around that
We can do it at the exact center of all of these we can do it based off of an actor or we can
Do it based off the world origin for now
I'm going to click on center min Z and press OK and what we're going to get is a new
Save level as dialog so we're going to save this as
MT
Underscore zero one and I'm going to click save and what you're going to see happen here is
Instead of now having a group of static meshes like I did before so let me come up here to my static mesh folder
I'm going to collapse this you can see here now what I have is this one single
Actor, and if I hit ctrl B
You'll see it's also been added as a level so I can drag this in and you'll notice that I can use this
Multiple different times and every time what it's going to do is just add one of these level instance
actors in there so again
This is really useful for when I have things that are static and I want you know
Just kind of like, you know, maybe the player comes and runs around this
Maybe they don't get that high so they can't see over the mountains and you know
We make another version to hide the cracks on the side so we can really get this to help us kind of get
Started in areas or use this for areas that are
Often the distance and the players not meant to get to and we really want to have some
collection of assets to make it easier just for everything to
Be manageable with how many assets things can be made out of in a modern project
now
What if we want to add something a little more like I'm sure you're thinking what I want to add like a light or
Something else like an actor or a trigger or something
And this is where the packed level actors come in now packed level actors do the same thing behind the scenes
They replace those static meshes with instanced versions of the static meshes for performance
But they also allow you to include things like lights or different types of blueprints or triggers or things like that
So let's take a look at that inside of the editor. So we're gonna come over here and
Where is our little house we have a little house over here I think it's right here
So there's our little house. So we're gonna click on everything inside of the house here. All right, so there we go
There's everything inside the house
Now what we're gonna do is before I do that though
Actually, I should say let's come in here and add I'm gonna hold down L and click that's just gonna add a light
Right there. I'll add one over here
So now that we've done that let's come back here and select everything and then we'll also hold down the control key and grab our
Lights as well. There we go. And then we're gonna right-click level
create packed level actor again as we had with our
packed level instance we
Can select where the pivot point is going to be coming from for this one. I'm gonna hit center min Z
We're also going to be asked where we want this level to be saved. So we're gonna say
House underscore zero one and then also notice we're gonna get this BP
so we're gonna click Save right there as well and
we're gonna come out and
So you're thinking okay. Well got this blueprint that was kind of weird. What's going on?
So we do and have two different things. So first off, here's our house level blueprint
So that works and if we pull that in notice that we don't have our our lights inside of there
That's okay
What we can actually do for our lights is we just grab our house here
And our house is gonna have our lights inside of it
I think our light needs to actually be set to movable. So this is actually a great segue into
Editing now one of the other cool things about this is we can edit both of these and even break them apart into their
Individual components again if we want to use these just maybe as a starting point
So let's just pop over here and look at how we could fix this
So if I come here to my house zero two
I could just come here to my level and edit and if I come here to my light
I probably probably should set that to like movable and set this one to movable and click exit
yes, and
There we go. I've changed that now the other cool thing check this out if I was to bring this all the way over here
And let's say that for example, I don't know
We're gonna come in here and I can also click the edit here to edit it
I want to change this, you know
I don't know change this to yellow because that's what the color needs to be when it first starts off
We'll click exit and what's gonna happen is that's actually gonna
Populate and this one over here is gonna now be yellow
and as I said before we can also come to these and right click on this and
Break so we can break this and you know, we can't undo this action
But this is now break it broken this into its individual components
So we can use this kind of two different ways if we want we can use it for a level
Organizational purposes or we can use these to help us get started
Maybe this is the white box for a particular house
So we know that the you know house of this size is always going to be whoops always going to need to occupy
You know this amount of land
and then as things start to progress as your project starts to come together these eventually get replaced with
their proper models so again the
Editing of level instances or actors can allow you both a
performance gain as well as make it easier to share things that you've crafted out of multiple objects and
Also account for utilizing things like lights blueprints and triggers inside of your projects